how's it going reject nation greg here
today's december 31st 2020. if you're
watching this
that means i'm already dead
no obviously not i uploaded this video
i'm getting ready to go work out but
before i do
i mean i gotta work out because i've
just been eating like [ __ ] since
christmas
it needs to end be healthy in 2021
so i wanted to hop on here because
out of all the years of doing youtube
i've never woken up on december
31st and had a feeling of
overwhelming gratitude
you know how like you know most
youtubers will say
like love you guys thank you everyone
for being here love every single one of
you
and i think like you know how in life
you might just say thank you we're sorry
and it's kind of just a
casual way of saying it you might not be
feeling it i think the same can be said
for
youtubers ourselves included if we say
it that
like we we mean it we were saying it but
a lot of times we don't really
feel it that strongly sometimes it's
just a thing that we're saying but this
morning
without having to can't point them i
just woke up and i just i really felt it
and i was reflecting on why and i kind
of just wanted to hop on here
really quick and share with you
guys why because it
it's mainly thanks to all of you
see the first half of 2020 especially
for us because 2020
in total has has been a rather rough
year
you know like i don't even need to
explain everything do i we all know how
20 toys and rough and we all have a lot
of unique circumstances to how it
has been rough and in my personal life
especially the first half of this year
there's a lot of emotional obstacles to
have to overcome and
it was kind of disheartening and channel
related wise when people were constantly
telling me of
you know everyone's at home i feel like
more people should be watching your
videos
i'm like i don't really know why and
then i i
was thinking maybe it had something to
do with the fact that you know most
months
out of the years we mainly do like the
big trailers and that's usually
what helps keep the channel thriving and
such
and obviously other than stuff like dc
phantom and disney investor day there
weren't as many huge
trailers that that came out uh
consistently throughout the year but
i remember around i don't remember
exactly what month it was but
i didn't notice a change really started
occurring around june july area for us
and it was around the time we started
doing live streams more consistently
because i i always tell this is like a
mantra for us at this point whenever
before we do a live stream because we
usually give like a couple hours heads
up
we don't really get that many people who
watch our live streams we know they tend
to be a little more on the intimate side
because of the
how do people actually show up but i
always
tell john no matter how many people show
is literally what i say like no matter
how many people show up
doesn't matter if we get super chats or
not
let's just entertain whoever's here and
give them a sense of escape
escapism just for the little bit of time
they're with us so it's always the goal
just to have fun
and i kind of noticed that we sort of
carry that
energy and vibe and mentality uh for
every as many videos as possible we
upload almost every single day so we're
not always on our a game we're not
always as
energetic as we'd like to be from a
natural place right
so i would say though
that most of the time
we really do our best to make sure we're
coming from a place of having
fun and i don't know if that's what made
a shift around the june july
area because i feel like especially in
the last two to three months of this
year
a lot of decision making of what to
cover it comes down to
you know will this be fun to do i mean
there have been times where we've done
reactions to certain videos that we just
never put up
because we were like there's nothing
really to talk about
i don't really feel like this would be
fun so no let's not do it that's
happened
quite a handful of times or like this
would just be boring
um for anyone who watches this so no i
don't think we should put this up
but like even like the batman video
yesterday that we put up about robert
pattinson
like how we thought that news was just
so fake and ridiculous
but the decision came down to this would
be fun to talk about it though like how
can we make this more fun
bottom line is
i did notice through reviewing analytics
lately how despite not having this
stuff that's normally presented for us
every single year we're doing youtube
somehow we still gained about 70 000
subscribers
and honestly our view count has been way
more consistent and
the total amount of views per month have
been
much higher and yes it's like we cover a
little bit more stuff than just trailers
now we cover
you know like more a few more tv shows
this year as well
for for youtube and yada yada yada
the bottom line is is that
it's all because of you guys that this
channel has managed to have one of its
best years ever
despite it being the shitty year that
is 2020 for the real rejects
and because of the community here and
the support
we've had an amazing year channel
related wise
and i just think that's that's awesome
and i just wanted to say
thank you thank you for watching our
videos and thank you for being here
and thank you for helping me like
2020 is just like a year for the history
books is it not
i think we can all agree it's like a
year for the history books
and yet for this channel it's like
70 000 subscribers no small fleet
considering the fact that
the main thing that has always droven us
was like big a bunch of big trailers
every month
and yet somehow our views are better and
uh more consistent and like that support
is so moving to me especially after all
these years
and thank you like really
thank you and to everyone on our patreon
page too
like our patreon has grown and it's been
such a financially difficult year
for most people
and so to know that a lot of people are
showing their support a lot of people
are staying pleasure patreon
and um to see that it's been growing
there it's like because
we put up like videos there it's not i'm
not trying to do a patreon plug i'm just
saying like
the patreon as a has been a major
support for the channel and
trying difficult times for us and
to see that how much it's still grown
over there to see that all around like
the real rejects umbrella
has grown some more
all around and has it's been like one of
our best years ever
it means a lot because honestly like the
first part of 20
like the first half of 2020 really felt
like
it was gonna be rough um for for the
channel but you guys have really
carried us through and all i can say is
thank you i love every one of you for
watching our videos and i
i love all of you and i hope that you
all have a very safe
good 20 21 and then it could be better
than 2020
because despite how difficult it has
been for most of you guys to watch
our videos you guys have helped make
2020 an amazing year
for us for for the real rejects
specifically
so i want to say a special thanks to
obviously my fiance olivia
special thanks to john humphrey a
partner on crime
i want to say a special thanks to eric
over at
nerd chronic for helping to edit a lot
of those tv shows
uh reactions for us because that's made
a major difference too for the channel
and i also want to save room for
watching that batman trailer reaction
because that's my favorite trailer
reaction this year
[Laughter]
happy end of the year happy new year
guys and uh i hope
i hope 2021 ends up being a much better
year for you than 2020 is because
you know i i'll i'll add that i'll end
up with this it's like i know i know a
lot of other youtubers
who have said similar things to me in in
like over the phone and text messages of
how
2020 has actually surprisingly been a
better year for them youtube wise
as well so to the youtube community
to the viewers out there and to the
people who watch the video rejects
thank you all you guys are the best
seriously
keep kicking ass 20 21 probably gonna
take a couple days off january 1st
january 2nd continue
then pick up cobra kai sometime early
next week
much love
you